meantime we want to start tonight with
an actual insurrection real one an
insurrection against the rule of law
against civilization itself
that's been going on for more than a
year in the city of chicago
since the death of george floyd last may
chicago's mayor lori lightfoot
has embraced every part of the equity
and inclusion agenda
lightfoot banned the police from chasing
criminals even in the case of some very
serious offenses
her d.a refuses to prosecute many crimes
the results nearly 200 more people have
been murdered this year than last
many more dead people hundreds yesterday
there was yet another mass killing in
chicago watch
denise mathis brittanya rogers blakely
and shermitria williams all killed in
chicago's latest mass shooting
the shooting happened at about 5 45
tuesday morning
inside a home on the 6200 block of south
morgan street in englewood
of the eight people that were shot four
died the other four victims are in the
hospital two of them reported in
critical condition
the attack is the third mass shooting in
chicago in a little more than a week
did you hear that that was the third
mass shooting in chicago in just
over a week each one of them was a far
greater human tragedy than anything that
happened at the capitol on january
6th but as the bodies in chicago
accumulate the people who run the city
barely notice
in fact they made it possible four days
before christmas a 28 year old named
marvin flanagan murdered a man during a
home invasion flanigan should have been
in jail at the time
he was a five-time felon with
convictions for armed robbery
but officials let him out and then he
promptly committed murder
this is now common in the city of
chicago marvin flanagan is just one of
dozens of criminals who've been let out
of chicago jail recently only to go on
to shoot or murder someone else
lori lightfoot did this but she accepts
no responsibility for doing it
instead she blames firearms and demands
more money from the federal government
cities individually cannot tackle this
problem on its own
we just cannot in chicago we've done
absolutely everything possible and we
need help
from the federal government because this
is a national
problem it's a national problem the gun
problem it's a national one
is it really chicago has long had some
of the strictest gun control in the
nation the state of montana has
virtually no gun control who's got a
higher murder rate
this entire conversation is nonsense
lori lightfoot has no idea what she's
talking about in fact as you can
probably tell
she's not very interested as long as her
own security detail shows up on time
lightfoot doesn't think a lot about
crime
what she thinks about is radical social
change and this week she got an assist
from the united states congress
starting this saturday our country is
getting a new independence day to
supplant the old one
which people like lori lightfoot
complained was racist not a single
member of
either party in the senate opposed it
republicans in fact co-sponsored the
resolution
happy that my bill to recognize
juneteenth as a national holiday just
passed the senate
wrote john cornyn a supposedly
conservative senator from texas
laurie lightfoot is thrilled by this
unlike john cornyn
lori lightfoot understands the power of
symbols
they're immensely important that's why
we have them for flag day on monday a
holiday designed to honor the american
flag speaking of symbols
lori lightfoot is flying something
instead called the pan-african flag
you're seeing a shot of it on your
screen right now
it's now up in city hall in chicago that
and the juneteenth flag
watch we must also recognize
that freedom has been illusory for far
too many
american residents including black
people
so we must embrace all american history
and today on juneteenth we will be
raising
another flag the juneteenth flag
freedom has been illusory really what's
she saying well she's saying that
your old independence day and the nation
that it celebrated
was all a lie so this is the kind of
thing that lori lightfoot spends
her time doing that and berating her
staff
thanks to an open records request from
the chicago tribune we've got some of
lori lightfoot's emails and it turns out
she is every bit the person you imagined
she was
in january for example lori lightfoot
told her staff quote
i need office time every day exclamation
point
she wrote that very same line 16 times
in a row i need office time every day i
need office time every day
i need office time every day and so on
13 more times
demented and then for clarity quote
not just once a week or some days every
day exclamation point
and then lightfoot wrote that exact same
line ten more times
in a row so she needs help
but it's not as much help as her staff
needs someone ought to stage a hostage
extraction for their sake
lightfoot ended her email with this if
this doesn't change immediately i will
just start unilaterally cancelling
things
every day have i made myself clear
finally question mark exclamation point
so as the bodies piled up hundreds more
under her tenure as mayor
you gotta wonder how much time did lori
lightfoot take to write all of that
was she shaking and spitting and
screaming as she did
of course she was here's laurie
it's terrifying but apparently it didn't
work
it wasn't enough things did not improve
in the mayor's office despite
those missives in may of last year
lightfoot announced a new policy for
memos that arrive
late late memos won't just be rejected
they will be
torn by rage-filled fingers into
millions of tiny little pieces
and cast into the wind like chaff given
the right weather conditions
late memo fragments might blow over lake
michigan and fall onto grand rapids
in an email to her staff lori lightfoot
attached a picture of ripped up
documents
for emphasis lori lightfoot human
shredding machine
and yet still somehow this person
remains the mayor
of america's third largest city how long
can that continue
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else